welcome to the special edition of
Hannity scandals of the left i'm
kimberly guilfoyle in tonight for Sean
the party that often prides itself for
being a so-called champion for women is
now facing widespread turmoil after
multiple high profile Democrats have
been accused of sexual misconduct
Minnesota senator Al Franken was forced
to issue yet another apology yesterday
after two more women came forward and
accused him of inappropriately grabbing
them from behind bringing the total
number of alleged sexual harassment
victims to for the apology read in part
quote I'm a warm person I hug people
I've learned from recent stories than in
some of those encounters I crossed the
line for some women and I know that any
number is too many I feel terribly that
I've made some women feel badly and for
that I am so sorry and I want to make
sure that never happens again
senator Al Franken is not the only
Democrat facing accusations of sexual
misconduct longtime congressman john
conyers is also accused of harassment
including one instance where he held a
meeting in his underwear
unfortunately the so-called party of
women's rights isn't quite united in its
response to this inner party sexual
harassment with some calling for Conyers
to step down while others tried to dodge
the subject watch this Conyers says it
didn't happen you say he should resign
why because enough is enough at this
point what I am voicing publicly is what
every single private citizen is saying
across America why are the rules for
politicians in Washington different than
they are for everyone else once we start
getting into the realm of politicians
well let's get the Ethics Commission
into it and you know let's investigate
this you know and take forever to come
up with a conclusion do you think
congressman Conyers you sit with him on
judiciary should he resign well I think
the ethics process should precede the
allegations against congressman Conyers
are clearly disturbing disappointing
deeply troubling the ëthis investigation
should be
roll it should be swift it should be
comprehensive so is it time for Conyers
and Franken to resign and will selective
moral outrage over instances of sexual
misconduct fracture the Democratic Party
joining us now is Fox News contributor
Lieutenant Colonel Allen West RNC
spokesperson Kaley mcenany and Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
thank you for joining me on this a
Friday evening lots to discuss and
Geraldo I'll begin with you according to
Senator Franken spokesperson he is
expected to speak to reporters on Sunday
what do you think that he might say or
should say to convince people that he
should in fact not resign well he's been
apologizing you know non-stop kind of
Kimberly and I expect I fully expect
that he'll say that he's sorry but that
he's staying in his seat you know I just
have to make a quick observation I I
hate when I the intensity of our
reaction to some of these allegations is
directly related to the political party
of the person being accused I want to
have the same reaction regardless of
whether the perpetrator is a Republican
or a Democrat the other thing I want to
say is that I understand when someone's
an accused rapist or like Bill Cosby or
an accused sexual predator like Judge
Moore is but sex harassment what is this
a big wave now what is it exactly
Kanye's wears his underwear in front of
a staffer you know he's an 88 year old
man I don't know I heard someone say
today it definitely was not sexual you
know the thing that bugs me about
congressman Conyers specifically is that
he got somehow the taxpayer to to pay
his settlement for you know for
allegedly you know being out of line
with one of his staffers that's what I
don't ask because he's 88 and it's not
sexy it is under I think this is
ridiculous it's about also how he makes
the other person feel it's totally
inappropriate you shouldn't be having or
conducting any kind of meeting like that
we're not giving an age pass for
something like that my my problem
Kimberly is very simple if it's not
criminal conduct that's being alleged
then what is it exactly it's going to
the ethics committee they say now
the Ethics Committee cannot by law
review something that is a crime if it's
a crime that is alleged then it goes to
the US Attorney's Office as you as a
great attorney already know but you know
so people minimize the ethics committee
the ethics committee is not even going
to get it if they're alleging a crime if
they're not alleging a crime that what
exactly is this so we're using this new
wave of sex harassment allegations to
get back at bed bosses or or hated
ex-lovers you know I just worry that
we've started down a very slippery slope
here Kimberly well there has to be of
course lieutenant colonel some you know
due process in a situation some
standards and also you know adjudicating
the situation in terms of developing a
fact pattern verifying witnesses and
information but I don't think in any way
it should minimize the seriousness you
know of the allegations they should be
taken seriously in thoroughly
investigated you're absolutely right
Kimberly and what is kind of disturbing
for me is the fact that who are these
people that decide who are the people
that decide which women are to be
believed and which women are not to be
believed and I think that is the what is
most you know confusing about this
situation and if this goes all the way
back to let's be very honest with Bill
Clinton and the women who accuse him but
yet they were not supposed to be
believed and they were attacked but yet
when you have a 40-year old case and
when you talk about Roy Moore then all
of a sudden that's to be believed but
yet when it comes to Al Franken this is
just a guy who likes to hug people and
it's no big deal or with John Conyers we
want to look a different way there has
to be a consistency in what we see
happening out there and I just don't see
that consistency all right Kelly how do
you see this situation you know it's
tough because it can have some effect in
terms of on gender lines is how women
perceive it or someone who's been in a
situation like this you know we're all
for due process and adjudicating it and
determining the credibility and the
veracity of the witnesses and their
statements it is more complicated when
things go back way in time as Lieutenant
Colonel has posited well Kimberly that's
right and that's why every single one of
these cases has to be looked at in
isolation they can't
lumped together every single person
should be heard I think it's very
troubling what we've seen particularly
from congressman Conyers when you see
someone who paid 27,000 dollars of
federal taxpayer money to settle with a
woman who is accusing him of firing her
for not accepting a sexual advances that
in and of itself that misuse of the
taxpayer funds should be enough to call
for his resignation but what we're
seeing Kimberly really is a case of the
powerful preying on the people it defies
party lines it's people and powerful
positions be it in hollywood be it a
media be it in congress preying on the
american people it's the swamp that
donald trump talked about all along okay
well you know her Aldo the Democratic
Party liberals have made themselves out
to be the champion of women's rights I
mean do you think we can expect a march
on Washington on behalf of the women
that have made these allegations or been
victimized or had to sit there and kind
of a meeting with Conyers in his
underwear
well I wouldn't I wouldn't hold my
breath on that one Kimberly but let me
just give you an example you mentioning
Franken now frankenz famous now
notorious or infamous for patting the
butt of someone they took a picture with
allegedly so that's outrageous we say
what about the the allegation that's
gained quite a bit of legitimacy and
currency that George HW Bush Bush 41
from his wheelchair tells a joke when
women say stand alongside him who's your
favorite comedian mine is David
Copperfield
you know and he Pat's the ladies on the
butt I mean if it's outrageous for
Franken it's outrageous for George HW
Bush and you talk about senior citizens
he's what 93 years old I know but you
were the one that seemed to be making
some kind of exception for those that
are elderly or infirm after a certain
age that they get some kind of you know
get out of sexual harassment jail free
card maybe I was speaking you know as a
senior citizen myself but my main point
with Conyers particularly is that the
allegations as now that's one thing when
he was going after allegedly some
subordinate and that's the one that got
paid off with the taxpayer money that's
outrageous and the fact that the he
somehow weasel those way so he didn't
have to pay it out of his own pocket the
fact that it was secret for so long
also outrageous I think Congress is
totally complete
I think I'm right and left Democrat
Republican I can give you a hundred
cases where Mark Foley Vitter
you know Craig go on and on and on how
many times that our leaders have been
guilty of these mistakes Kimberly well
also in taxpayer money shouldn't go to
have to pay for these misdeeds and this
kind of you know abuse that people have
to suffer in the workplace I make
Kayleigh what's your response when he
brings up the other side you feel
there's a double standard you know or
hypocrisy of any sort no I think from
the Republican Party you've seen an
unequivocal stance from both the
President and from our party saying if
any allegation is true that individuals
should step down it's a clear standard
but it's one we haven't seen embraced by
the Democrats they've covered for Bill
Clinton for three decades
and now with congressman Conyers you
have one Democratic lawmaker as of this
morning calling for him to resign maybe
it's a handful now but where is the
consistency from their party don't cover
for your own be the party of women
that's what you claim your art well
you're not acting like it
alright well lieutenant color how about
that because you know they do really
hold themselves out to be the gold
standard but the response an assessment
and you know being proactive on behalf
of women in the sense of the liberals
and Democrats has not been their most
you know worthy shining moment no you're
absolutely right the actions do not
match up with the rhetoric and you
brought up the point I'm waiting for
Madonna or Ashley Judd or some of these
other individuals to come out and you
know start screaming from the rafters
but you're not going to hear that I was
in Congress when the Anthony Weiner
incident came down and you know for him
to have done the things that he did and
then continue to maybe even run for
mayor of New York City I mean you got to
put these things in perspective but if
Congress wants to do the right thing
Congress needs to let us know in full
transparency who are the people that
were the recipients of these
taxpayer-funded bailouts for their poor
behavior
that is something that they need to do
or else it will be seen as some big boys
club I I think he may say you know great
point Alda which there has to be a full
and thorough a fair accounting from both
sides in terms of how these things were
handled investigation back to understand
that where were the taxpayer
funds allocated to and after what kind
of you know due process etc to be able
to vet the allegations and then also to
act in a way you know expeditiously to
make sure that there was some kind of
like justice and there were some kind of
reprisal and some kind of education
going forward so that this would in fact
not continue to occur well you have
wieners going to jail so justice has
been served
in his case you've got this this other
Republican Carmen Barton out of Texas
who just got caught sending lewd
pictures of his genitalia to girls he
were he was courting what's what's he
gonna do it was in a relationship that
he was having a relationship with these
different women and that there was some
back-and-forth in terms of you know
please don't try to blackmail me with
these photos etc that he was in talk to
Capitol Police you know I was at Polo
the restaurant that you love also in New
York and Kathie Lee Gifford was there
Erica and I saw Kathie Lee at a table as
we were leaving and and she says to me
Kathie Lee looks up says to Erica and
and me can you believe what's going on
right now I don't even know who to say
hello to I'm afraid that the someone's
going to consider it
sexual harassment I mean it may be you
know it when you see it but my point is
you needs clearer standards and you need
you need a standardized repercussions
for bad behavior obviously a criminal
case Weiner goes to jail right good
riddance that's too bad rubbish that's
where we should go but you know I think
that the Congress has to clean its own
house all right we're Titans holiday
Kayleigh I'm gonna give you a final word
as well yeah I would just say that we
have a systemic problem that when an
accuser brings forth a claim against a
powerful lawmaker they're instructed to
go to immediate counseling and then
their name in the name of that
congressman is shrouded in secrecy it's
the powerful versus the people it's
inexcusable and Congress needs to clean
this out all right lieutenant colonel
Congress a lot more needs to be done
here it seems like they've been a pretty
failing pretty abysmally yes a lot more
needs to be done I find it very
interesting that you have Congress up
there deciding how much money that we
can keep ourselves as they go through
this time
tax bill process but yet they're using
our money to take care of their at poor
behaviors yeah absolutely unbelievable
bad bad deeds okay thank you so much
panel fantastic to have you here tonight